It's really important for me not to be hyperbolic
in this segment because this is so serious,
but to act
Lee communicate to you the dire situation
that we're in with regard to the 2020 election.
The language might sound like what is normally
hyperbolic language, but in this case it just
accurately reflects the circumstances.
What I'm talking about is that the 2020 election
is not going to be a fair election in what
we, most of us imagine when we say a fair
election, if a Democrat is to defeat Donald
Trump in 2020 it's going to be despite all
sorts of underhanded tactics and endless betrayals
of the type of election that our founding
fathers wanted us to have year in and year
out.
Foreign interference happened in 2016 Trump
just said to George Stephanopoulos on national
TV that he'd welcome help again in 2020 republicans
including Mitch Mcconnell or simply blocking
any bill to secure the election from foreign
interference, which we've talked about.
The big voting machine lobbyists are now donating
to Mitch Mcconnell's campaign, which we've
talked about voter suppression, not voter
fraud.
Remember voter suppression, which is this
package of policies that Republicans have
been pushing for decades to limit voting hours,
to limit voting locations in poorer nonwhite,
democratic leaning areas, combined with using
the boogeyman of voter fraud as a sort of
straw man to justify voter purges and voter
id laws and so much more gerrymandering, which
already favors Republicans because of the
urban rural divide just systemically, but
it's used even more grossly to favor Republicans
and how the congressional districts are currently
drawn the very real possibility that Donald
Trump, if at any point he truly starts to
believe that he is losing rather than writing
off all the polls, it's fake panics and tries
to get us into a military conflict.
It could be Iran, could be Venezuela, could
be, I mean almost anything with this guy that
does affect voters and it will be another
thing that Democrats and whoever is the eventual
democratic nominee is going to need to overcome.
So what I want to convey to you today is that
even if we deal with any three of these four
major ways in which this is not going to be
a fair election, it is going to be an uphill
battle where the Democratic nominee, whoever
he or she ultimately is, is going to need
to overcome significant slanting in the infrastructure
of this election in order to actually win.
Now, that doesn't mean that it's impossible,
but what you need to do is immediately put
out of your mind the idea that it might be
a fair election because it's just not going
to be okay.
There's a rolling stone article pointing out
that Republicans are more than willing to
help make this an unfair election.
So if you are even considering like for a
split second not voting because of all of
these things, you should rethink that.
Okay?
If you say the election is fundamentally slanted
towards Donald Trump's reelection, so I'm
not going to vote, that is the exact wrong
reaction to be having.
You need to vote because your vote is so much
more important given that this is going to
require if the Democratic candidate is going
to win, uh, going above and beyond all of
these systemic factors that have the playing
field slanted in the direction of Donald Trump
the last midterm.
Okay?
The 2018 midterms, that also was not a fair
election.
Democrats were able to pick up records, seats
in the house because people voted in such
numbers that we were stronger than the lack
of fairness that is implicit in the system
in a way that tilts towards Republicans in
the ways that I described.
So you need to realize that we're fighting
people who don't care about fairness, okay?
The Republican Party decided decades ago that
they don't care about being fair or behaving
appropriately or running elections in a way
that is in line with what the founding fathers
wanted.
This is basically sport to them.
Okay?
It's just wins and losses.
That's all it is.
It's strikes and balls or whatever.
All that matters is wins on the board.
If the policy's destroy farmers in the Midwest,
if they destroy democracy at its core, whatever,
if they destroy the middleclass, as long as
this Republican Party sees that they are quote,
winning and checking off the right boxes on
the scoreboard, that is all that they care
about.
So on the one hand, we can't stoop to their
level because we are not like them.
But if we don't start winning somehow, we
will never take them out of power.
And that's what the left needs to understand.
And that's why a lot of my focus lately has
been on trying to unite the left rather than
allowing these arbitrary and rigid divisions
of the left to fracture the left.
Because we're up against significant unfairness
in this upcoming election.
So if you don't vote, we don't even have a
chance.
Even if you do, we still need to overcome
all the injustice of the system that they've
successfully put in place over the last several
decades for their own gain at their own, for
their own advantage.
So that should I hope, motivate you to vote
rather than say that I'm not even going to,
if you disagree with my take on this, I want
to hear from you.
If you think that this scenario means you
shouldn't even bother voting, I vehemently
disagree with you and I hope you'll call in
later this week when I take live calls and
confront me about it because it's something
I absolutely want to talk to you about because
it is so important.
It is.
I, I, I don't want to be hyperbolic, but the
reality is extreme and we need to understand
that.